if you still haven't received your  twelve hundred dollar stimulus check you  can have until now tomorrow to claim it  the irs said roughly nine million people  who were qualified to receive a check  when they were issued back in march were  not registered online so never got one  the irs commissioner testified before  congress today  urging americans to register before  tomorrow afternoon  he says those who didn't claim their  checks may not know they are  eligible talking about somebody who  normally does not file a tax return  and a lot of people don't have to every  year because they don't meet the  threshold minimum threshold that is of  income to file a return  he went on to encourage anyone who  thinks they are eligible  and haven't received a check to register  online  or contact the irs immediate